[Music]
today's question comes from laura in
tennessee our family has been a dave
ramsey family i always agreed with the
quote expensive college is a ripoff idea
and my older son is in community college
now my younger son announced at age
seven that he wanted to become an
economist and fix poverty and wealth
inequality almost a decade later he
still wants to become an economist he
wants to go to harvard or wharton and
feel strongly that going to such a
school would help him develop
connections that would allow him to
advance his goals as jobs for economists
are mostly appointed we can afford to
pay his way but is it really worth 250
000 in tuition alone
hmm
there's a lot going on here i'm
intrigued by it i'd personally this is
my personal take i don't think it's
worth 250 000 dollars to go be an
economist for the connections
but if they have the cash to do it and
that's something they want to do for
their son
that's the decision they can make but
personally if i'm if i'm mom and dad i'm
going no we're not doing this
okay
this kid is obviously a child of great
intellect and he's also a super nerd
yeah seven years old he wanted two seven
years old i want to be an economist and
do away with wealth inequality
seven-year-old says that come on strange
ones very smart ones yeah that's an
unusual child
and so uh in a good way maybe but maybe
maybe
um
and it sounds like [ __ ]
now the child is she said almost a
decade later so he must be 17 close to
college
a decade or so 16 years old okay let me
help you with this at 16 years old you
do not know what you're talking
about you're so full of crap that it's
unbelievable
i want to go to harvard because i can
make connections because economist jobs
are all appointed
horse crap
you're 16.
you do not know what you're talking
about
you don't know what you're talking about
young child
this is why you have parents thank god
you need parents you need a keeper even
if you're a very smart and unusually
bright young man who has had a focused
since you were a child a little child
but um so here's the thing there are
economists in all parts of life
um i have a friend who is one of the
best known economists in the world he
invented the laffer curve art laffer
he has a phd from economics i believe it
was cambridge if i remember
i served in reagan's cabinet and he
served on the in the trump cabinet as
well wrote the last trump tax law is
absolutely brilliant and made almost
none of his money
doing those things
he instead manages
wealth
for others i'll just leave it at that
and um like lots of wealth with bees on
the end of it billions
and so um and art's like 80 something
years old now he's brilliant he's again
he's a friend he's still a real shy in
the area probably one of the best-known
economists on the planet that's alive at
this moment in the top five anyway
and so um
he he would tell you that education is
vital and education is important and he
would tell you cambridge was worth the
money uh because of the path that he
ended up going on but i will tell you
that that job
there's only about three of those
in the world
and the rest of time the economist ends
up working for a mutual fund company
or the economist ends up working for a
financial planning company or the
economist ends up working for
a large
corporate
entity that needs some economic
predictions
and models run out on their
revenue projections and an economist and
in all of those cases there's no roi on
what you're talking about
so these schools are not better schools
and no they do not provide better
connections they're just more famous
let me also let me point out to you this
here's an example of what i'm talking
about
wall street journal did a study a few
years ago
and 78
of the forbes
i'm sorry 78 of the s p 500 the 500
largest publicly traded companies
on the stock exchange 78 8 out of 10 of
the ceos graduated from state schools
i'll help you with that again
of the largest 500 companies traded on
the stock exchange 8 out of 10 ceos
graduated from
state schools
they went to
the university of fill in the state but
dave they're missing out on the
connections and harvard but they're the
ceo of household name companies
and by the way the cfos same situation
the cos
same situation
the chief digital officers some of them
didn't even graduate from college
and so yes you can get a degree there
but this idea that the connections you
make in college are going to open your
doors and make you successful is as dumb
as the idea that the degree
is going to make you successful what
makes you successful at the end of the
day is you
education is important it's even vital
but where you get it and who you are
connected to there is no data to back up
this theory of where you went to school
matters
that these prestigious universities that
there's an roi on them we cover a bunch
of this in borrowed future i was just
going to say this is all reminding me
very heavily of the bard future
documentary where we go into this and we
talk about is is school worth it are
degrees worth it what about trade
schools and state schools versus the big
name and what we found out was that
there's there's really no correlation
between success
of hey i went to harvard or i went to a
state school
learn to play golf join a country club
for a tenth of what you would pay at
that school and go get a degree from a
state school and you'll be better off
and if this kid it really has the
intellect that i think he has i think he
can get scholarships they're going to be
knocking at the door trying to get he
can go for free that's fine but that
isn't what she asked we can afford to
pay is it really worth 250 000
no it's not worth a quarter of a million
dollars no it's not no no but is he
smart enough that he's going to be just
fine and maybe he could be an economist
and love what he does sure yeah but i
wouldn't pay a quarter million dollars
for the pleasure of it yeah and uh
it's uh um but don't just because your
kid has
an unusual proclivity for
articulating his ideas at seven years
old
does not mean he actually knows what
he's talking about
to get poor 17
and sometimes parents get all enamored
with their kids wishes and um that's
just why you're supposed to be parents
and you know it's like i don't know i
had one guy called me from mission he
said my daughter told me she's going to
this expensive school what am i going to
do and i said well you messed up a long
time ago because my daughter didn't tell
me stuff i tell her stuff that's how
that works so that's where we got
confused we got confused how this works
got confused as to who's in charge here
by the way it's my money
so um because she's trying to make a
decision
you know reasonably and i'm and i'm not
picking on your kid your kid's obviously
a special child in a lot of good ways uh
and that that's all fine but it does not
mean he's wise
and uh so his
opinion about the connections is
something he heard
from somebody or read
with an internet article
this is the ramsey show